watching CNN and these other outlets
Fall Apart is good because they're
narrative machines but one of the most
important things that's often overlooked
by the right conservatives Libertarians
or whatever is creating culture that
inspires young people so right now with
you here we have a lot of people
chatting how they're huge fans of the
Misfits but you're also here challenging
The Establishment I'm curious your
thoughts on how do we create an
anti-establishment uh cultural apparatus
and more importantly how is it that so
many anti-establishment musicians just
flipped and went full pro-war Pro
lockdown that blew my mind how that how
did that happen I think that and it's
not just because I'm here I think that
you and and your team and everybody here
is the perfect example of what needs to
be built for this parallel economy or
these parallel structures that will push
that will build what what needs to be
built not only do you do this sort of
thing and have conversations about all
of this but you're still you're you're
creating shows and music and
entertainment all these different things
things and intention has a lot to do
with that your energy and where where
your perspectives and your your your
friends and your um your colleagues
where they're coming from they're coming
from a good place and so that resonates
um
you know so I think that that's that's
that's a good thing when we we see these
CNN or MSNBC when we see the viewership
going down and these companies starting
to shrink in size that's a good thing
because we can fill that vacuum or we
need to fill that vacuum with these
things out that we're building well so
so one of the reasons
we here at timcast.com become a member
are focusing on cultural Investments
like pop culture crisis is a show very
similar to this format hosted by Brett
dasovich and Mary Morgan but it's pop
culture because we were like not
everybody likes politics we want to
create a show where we can build
influence in other areas Tales from the
inverted world is Honduras Thompson
meets The X-Files and of course we're
doing music we've got some skateboarding
and rollerblading and scooting plans
we're doing this though mostly because
I'm looking at you know like some of the
bands that I grew up listening to that
were basically saying F the machine are
now saying yay the machine yes like how
did that happen
well I think a lot of that comes with
ignorance I think a lot of that also
comes with
um people like us and I hate saying that
but but people that
um it takes a certain person to say
maybe I'm wrong
like I'm going to take this position
about whatever maybe I'm wrong let me go
see if I'm wrong and then spend time
finding out if you're wrong and and
recalibrating your position if if it
needs to be because doing that you gain
knowledge you you're able to articulate
your position you know what you know and
why you know it
um and not just well you know because
gender queer book told me that and so
therefore that's the way that I feel
but in order to do that I think that
there's certain you know morals and
integrity that that needs to be built
into someone and that goes into a whole
conversation about parenting and and
everything but you know with the with
the musicians in in the entertainment
industry I think a lot of it certainly
is ignorance but also I think that
there's some people that perhaps they
might well I know I know that there's
some people out there that know what the
truth is and know what is kind of going
on
but there's there's there's fear and
there's selfishness involved in it
because they don't want to lose anything
they don't want to lose their contract
they don't want to lose they don't want
people saying bad things about them on
their Facebook oh God forbid they lose
their Facebook what would they do oh my
God and so and so they just go along to
get along uh regardless of of what their
heart is is saying you know the
Believers believe you know when you have
the holy spirit inside you you have that
discernment that at some point if you
continue if you just keep rejecting that
your heart hardens and then you don't
hear that anymore and so you're able to
just go full on
um to you know any any port you you want
um and so there's a lot there's a lot of
that in the entertainment industry
there's a lot of that in the in in the
music industry because everybody wants
to be popular and loved and be that
person and have the lights on them
that's what it's about and we'll take
any route they need to to get there and
hold on to it same thing in politicians
it's it's power you people you know you
you want that power it's difficult to
take a position and find yourself
completely alone like where do you feel
alone and if these bands
uh shout out to The Offspring for firing
their drummer because he was unable to
get vaccinated due to medical condition
if bands like that stood up and said
sorry guys all of our shows are being
canceled uh to all of our fans who spend
all this money we we are unfortunately
unable to do the show because the venues
won't allow our drummer in what do you
think would happen when 5 million ticket
holders call Ticketmaster all at the
same time Ticketmaster is going to be
like why is our system breaking down
they're going to contact the venues and
be like what are you doing why are these
shows getting canceled and they're gonna
say well we we told The Offspring they
weren't allowed to have their drummer in
the building what are you well we have a
contract well well the government passed
a law then everyone's going to start
calling up the local governments what
are you doing we got 5 million cancel
contracts are falling apart if one band
just said we will cancel every show it
would cause a chain reaction that would
make it all the way to the point where
large lobbyists and investors would be
standing at the desk of the mayor of New
York saying I will destroy you
politically unless you fix this problem
and they'll be like okay okay we'll
rescind this but no the whiny pathetic
establishment loses The Offspring said
uh how about we just fire our drummer of
17 years when we we our families have
hung out together
screw them I'd rather make money and
fire him these people are [ __ ]
pathetic okay now I'm swearing you're
right though I mean at least there was a
pathetic move I don't want to judge them
their personalities because I don't know
them but I I think it was a weak move if
anything they have so much power to
control culture I said this I've said
this about a lot of things I agree with
you I agree patreon they they they
banned this guy Robert Spencer he's an
Islamic scholar and he's controversial I
guess I'm not sure not Richard Spencer
Robert Spencer different guy and the
reason was if we don't MasterCard made
us do it if we didn't ban him then we'd
have to shut the whole site down and I'm
like I dare you yeah to I did MasterCard
I dare you to have the hundred million
plus subscriptions on the site disappear
and have each and every one of those
people calling you on the phone asking
you why you did it but no one has the
balls to actually be like I'll go for it
let's see what happens there were some
performers that would refuse uh to play
I think did they Chappelle do that was
he like I'm not performing if you're
going to have a vax mandate was he one
of those guys uh I know Chrissy Mayer
wouldn't wouldn't perform well now that
she's at Dave Chappelle's Fame yet but I
think I think Crowder and Ruben were
explicit I'm not sure uh they said they
moved venues I think it was Reuben
specifically was like we won't do a show
here and move down I'm not sure maybe it
wasn't Reuben yeah but um look I like
Joe Rogan but even he said here's what
we'll do I'll give you a refund if you
didn't want if you didn't know that they
were doing these rules and perhaps the
argument is that there were contracts
that locked Joe in and if he canceled it
could have caused him major damage or
something like that
but it's just like but that's that's the
I understand I understand that there's a
there's a lot at stake when you take
these positions however I I agree with
you that if some for like Offspring or
some of these larger acts I mean I I
didn't play The Whiskey A Go Go
for that reason because they had a
vaccine mandate in the city at the time
and I I said that I I didn't want to
play to a segregated audience nor did I
want someone to make a decision a
medical decision like that to come see
me that's crazy and so I just said I'm
not going to do it when things are
different I'll go back and I did I just
played there a couple weeks ago
um but I wish I had that power to you
know like The Offspring and some of
these other bands where if they just
stood up and said we already have so
much and there's and all of their fans
would not all of them but a lot of the
fans would get behind them or at least
say well what do you mean and then you
can have the larger conversation and
that would then put that pressure on the
record companies on the management
company on the lawyers on and all of the
the system that is the industry that
pushes back on these on these things let
me let me tell you let's go back to that
earlier segment where I was making fun
of Trudeau beating his hero and uh the
Elon Musk thing where he almost cried
died when told about Neil Armstrong the
first album I ever bought was Americana
by The Offspring the first tab book I
ever got was Americana by The Offspring
the second was ixnay on the hombre by
The Offspring followed by the tab book
for X9 and the Ombre and then of course
there's ignition then then I said wow I
better go back even further I got their
uh smash was obvious right so you're a
fan yeah this was the first this was the
band that got me into music this was the
band that at the time all that was was
all we had was pop so whatever was on
the radio was what it was didn't know
anything I didn't even know the names of
these bands and then my friend said
listen to this and handed me an
Americana CD and I learned all the songs
and I still have in my playlist I love
all of their 90s stuff and some of their
2000 stuff and I even like a lot of
their later stuff and then what a
letdown for them to be at a point where
I think Dexter sold the catalog for like
30 million or whatever to be so rich you
want for nothing and then to look into
the eyes of someone who's been there for
you for 17 years yeah their drummer and
say get out because I'm old that's
that's the dirtiest most vile
inhuman and old man not only that they
could have actually just been like bro
they're not gonna let you in the
building I'm sorry but don't worry we
will get someone to play with us but
we're not gonna let you down you're good
and we'll we'll do Studio stuff with you
and that's still in my opinion not the
strongest thing they could have done no
but I'd still be like I get it I get it
you know the fans want to show you don't
want to let them down but you're not
going to leave someone hanging instead
they're just like later bro and and the
crazy thing about this whole story is
that Pete Parada is the drummer he's
awesome he's done work with us his
doctor was like I recommend against this
because of the the potential medical
condition you have that's right okay and
then they're like get out yeah it's dirt
and if you would have listened to them
he could have got seriously hurt or
could have died but they still wanted to
to force him to do that to stay in the
band that that is cruel that is
absolutely evil uh Jim Brewer I think
did it the right way whenever people
were discriminating against somebody
whenever a venue had a vax mandate and
were segregating people based on
government compliance he said no I'm not
going to be performing here I'm only
going to be performing at places that
don't discriminate against bodily
autonomy against individuals deciding
their own Pathways their own life so
shouts out to Jim Brewer he was a real
one we should get him on the show he
does incredible work and I love his work
anyway he's a funny guy
that guy's Jim you are awesome yeah
Jim's incredible shout out to Jim
because because as much as we criticize
these horrible people we gotta shout out
the good people and promote them and all
the good stuff that they do as well yeah
Brewer's tremendous he's got a great
heart he's a family man he's great and
and absolutely has has taken the the
right path in all this and and obviously
has a hilarious perspective on it that
he puts in his routines but
I you would think certainly that
somebody like Pete you know who played
with these guys came up with these guys
there's a Brotherhood when you're on
tour with somebody and you know you're
in a band like that
um maybe it was 14 years I don't know
was it 14 or 17 maybe it was 14 years
that's a long that's a long long time
not a big difference it's a long time
it's not just being on tour it's not
just the tour thing and playing in a
band families and friends it's your
whole life it's your whole freaking
world that some and then all of a sudden
it's just well see you later dude yeah
dude you got to look up Pete Parada on
the internet at the face the picture of
his face he's like it's awesome looking
he's hitting it so hard he's on the
drums I'm trying to figure out when he
joined the offspring
face to face in 98 and then Offspring in
2007 so that'd be about 14 years ago 15
years ago the guy's amazing 2007 yeah 15
okay I was wrong yeah I was thinking
like wait a minute did I give him extra
years maybe it was 14. before that he's
with saves I couldn't I couldn't believe
that story when I heard it uh because it
because like my attitude is if something
happened like that and my response was
okay well we're gonna keep you know
moving forward I wouldn't terminate like
if I had somebody was working for me for
six months I wouldn't fire him I'd be
like you're cool dude we'll figure it
out yeah it's crazy and that's a scary
thing the people that you think have
your back
in in the past couple of years at least
in my experience you know I've I've lost
people in my life that walked away from
me that I've known for decades you know
20 years people that I was very very
close to that again because of the
pressure because of well I might lose my
Facebook and because you know I don't
know you've gone crazy or you know
people that know people that fell for
the delusion that believe the delusion
and the lies knowing me like knowing who
I am and and
knowing my heart but then saying yeah no
well we're going to go with with with
with this
whole thing
um and we're gonna that's that's a
that's scary that's like you when you
hear stories about you know when the
Nazis rolled into some of these the
different cities where just overnight
you know the pogroms these people they
went to school together they were family
and then all of us they're dragging each
other into the streets and they're
ripping their clothes off and they're
beating them
that's that's where we're at it's almost
like we're practicing for it and it's
just we're doing it online because
essentially you're assassinating people
you're killing them you're you're
ripping their whole world away
everything is gone all the people that
you love the your business these things
that you've worked gone Boop gone
and and and we're doing that in in that
synthetic world that's that's that's
built and it's not very far from from
the reality the physical part of this
let me let me let me just uh
let's multiply the concerns here the
fears here
we used to have brick and mortar stores
we still do sort of you drive down any
Main Street in Old cities what do you
see most the stores are closed yeah it's
true there's there's there first there
was Walmart now there's Amazon it's all
online so people start building their
businesses on Twitter Facebook and
Google I knew a guy who would sell
things on his web store and all of his
traffic came from Google people would
search for something and he would be in
the top five
Google changed their algorithm one day
his search dropped to the second page
his business evaporated yeah there's no
second page now here's where it gets
crazy
many people are building businesses on
Twitter Facebook and Google selling
things promoting things being
commentators oops you got banned your
business is erased imagine this when we
live in Mark Zuckerberg's metaverse fake
reality that he desperately wants us to
live in and you create a store with a
virtual environment that sells t-shirts
and people can walk in and they can buy
stuff and they can chat and then Mark
Zuckerberg walks in with a smile on his
face and says I'm deleting your store
and then you're gone everything you
worked for ceases to exist like that you
have a brick and mortar store it's a lot
harder to do you go into the metaverse
with digital business they can ban you
out right we launch a store we sell
t-shirts we got a t-shirt pen you can
buy it if you want
the company that hosts it could just
erase that store instantly and then
we're not selling any products it is a
nightmarish potential future unless we
stay conscious of what's happening and
fight for right for rules where this
crypto story comes in right we see the
dollar coming apart our economy coming
apart we see this what's happening with
with the fpx
um and and and now that there's going to
be the big push for the the
cryptocurrency regulations and
everything they got to get their hands
in that and cash isn't going to work we
need these regulations and we're going
to attach that to the social credit
score and we're going to take away
everything that's in this physical the
brick and mortar gone so that then that
ultimate control you say something that
is not part of the narrative you say
something that goes again you're whoa
you're gone well sorry what do you what
are you gonna do two things you know how
to grow corn no no don't worry about it
you will owe nothing and you will be
happy you will live in the Pod and you
will eat the bugs you will eat z-bugs
my favorite meme right now okay well one
I shouldn't say that but like a meme I
really like is the chicken that says I
will live in the Pod I will eat the bugs
and I will give you eggs
that's a good one oh my gosh chickens
are great you're talking about female
human eggs are they gonna be harvesting
people's eggs they might produce in a
laboratory yeah right now you are but I
wanted the metaphor extends to the next
70 years those goofy little things run
around eating bugs living in their
little pod and then we you know Kim goes
out there and she collects all their
little butt bounties crack them up and
have breakfast bring a little black
pepper on them can't be beefed I've race
chickens too yeah how many chickens you
got well we just had a weasel attack so
we're down yeah I raised Ducks too and
and weasel got in there big time so I I
lost upwards of nine ducks and three
chickens so my flock is down what
percent of your flock was that uh about
30 one weasel yeah it was actually two
my wife saw two a team of weasels yeah a
team of weasels they were working
together wow yeah they call people some
kind of Auto defense turret that can
identify what a chicken looks like yeah
using an AI and it like it pans past the
chickens and sees the weasel and it's
great it's crazy
it gets so frustrating sometimes you
just at least not you you know me I just
say let's just burn it all down I just
want to burn the whole Barn down it's
it's it's incredible such a little
little creature can cause so much damage
yeah we had we had a we had a snake get
in a couple times it was eating eggs but
the chickens are mostly fine the the
bigger issue we had is that um Roberto
Jr who is uh uh you know the son of
Roberto obviously and he's in charge his
mom died she had uh ovarian cancer
oh yeah yeah nothing we could do about
it we just didn't know that she just had
cancer we didn't see any signs she died
then we got to the the vet got a check
and they were like there's nothing could
have done it just happens yeah yeah I
think you're you're burning how you're
saying sometimes you get so frustrated
that you want to burn the barn down a
lot of people are feeling that like
sociologically like they're so
frustrated with the system and a lack of
hope that they say burn it all down but
like then you you get a chance hopefully
you get a chance to remember how awesome
it is to be alive in this experience of
love and pleasure and like learning and
protecting keep other life and it you're
reminded that it's worth keeping around
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time